The key to make Jasmine, the unit test
framework used in our sample repo
work with our build, is to use
a headless browser that we can execute
an instruct from the command line
because that's what gulp can deal with.
Luckily, such a browser exists.
It's called PhantomJS, and it's
basically a headless version of Webkit.
And you don't need to know
much more about it right now.
Just the fact that the
gulp-jasmine-phantom plugin uses that to
its advantage to actually run your
tests in a real browser environment.
Install PhantomJS first
using the instructor notes.
And then like always,
install gulp-jasmine-phantom via
npm in your project directory.
Then add a require to your gulp file,
like so.
Now all we need to do is to
create a new task called tests.
Use gulp.src to find the correct
test file we want to run,
then use a require with Jasmine.
The degradation setting tells
Jasmine to use PhantomJS.
If it's set to faults, it runs in a node
js environment instead which you'd only
want if you actually test node js code.
And finally the vendor setting needs to
point to our JavaScript source files,
as this plugin constructs its
own specrunner.html with those.
Now head back to your terminal and
run gulp tests to see Phantom JS and
Jasmine in action.